hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 7 video we got a ton
of great Easter eggs barry allen turned
a big corner in the episode and we
totally got another prison break
crossover in case you didn't watch arrow
season 2 robert knepper tear was the
clock king so he was reprising his
character there's also some totally
awesome Harrison wells moments that both
answered and raised some more questions
just more fun evidence to look at when
trying to figure out who he is careful
for spoilers from the episode though in
case you haven't seen it starting with
top five moments number five meet
blackout aka Farooq
he's another casualty of the STAR Labs
explosion but he's one of the first to
demonize Harrison wells in the eyes of
team flash I think being scientists
Caitlin and Cisco probably didn't care
quite as much about it as Barry did
Barry has liked the same alignment as
Superman which makes him a total Boy
Scout so Farooq is not the villain of
the episode Harrison wells is although I
wouldn't call him a villain so just some
backstory on Farooq from the comics he
did work with the Rogues but we mostly
see him during the flashpoint storyline
which is actually really cool because
Barry getting his powers back in the
episode looked kind of like a scene from
that comic in the context of the story
of flashpoint paradox Farooq is the most
powerful source of electricity on the
earth or you could think of him as like
the world's most powerful conductor
which is why Harrison wells wants to
study him his power is one of the few
things the flash is vulnerable to they
kind of explained it during the episode
fruit didn't steal Barry's powers
he just stole the energy that Barry
generated they made it sound like
Barry's cells store energy the same way
Superman's cells store solar radiation
and that's what gives them both their
abilities don't worry about the
specifics the show is always really good
about explaining the science behind what
they do
so whenever Harrison wells starts
messing with Farooq's DNA we'll get the
details for now Farooq is just gonna
chill in the meta prison I know it seems
like he's dead but they probably would
have destroyed the body if he was really
dead it's just another comic book thing
you know there's no such thing as true
death
even though supposedly girder died in
the episode I think what we should say
is that Barry thinks that they're dead
number 4 Barry is jacking around with
his powers way too much the flash is a
character takes himself way less
seriously than say Batman Superman even
green arrow he's a lot more like Hal
Jordan which is why they usually only
break through big men
and physical barriers after getting
their asses handed to them they're not
super zen characters so Barry getting
his butt kicked all the time is a very
necessary part of the process of
unlocking his potential I'll say
Harrison wells reaction to Barry Jackie
Rao's way more subdued than I thought it
would be we saw a little bit of the real
Harrison slip out when their lives were
on the line we have seen him lose his
in front of Cisco whenever he
learned about the cold gun I mean like
all of his energy is bent on getting
Barry up to a hundred percent that's
like the stratosphere power where Barry
can phase through solid objects break
into other dimensions travel through
time like you said more speed is the key
what he's going to do with that speed
once Barry achieves it is the big
question number three the clock King is
back it may have just been me but it
seemed like Robert nepers performance
was decidedly more comic book II than
when he was on arrow like it almost
sounded like he developed a whole new
accent some of his affectations sounded
a little bit more like the clock king
from the animated series he also spoke
more lines out of the comics like for
instance any time he did wordplay with
time and clocks
those were lines right out of the comics
like when he said time and time wait for
no man totally loved his performance at
the police station even though his
scenes felt a little uneven with the
STAR Labs scenes I think that's mostly
because I'm not super connected to the
iris character yet so when she was
kidnapped I didn't feel the same weight
that I felt on arrow when the old count
vertigo threatened to inject felicity to
be fair that was arrow season two and
the flash hasn't even finished half of
its first season yet so I'll totally
give Candice Patton in the writers the
benefit of the doubt I mean it's really
hard for any other female character in
the arrowverse to hold screen time with
felicity what I mean by that is that
anytime any other women are on screen
with Felicity your attention is
typically drawn to her regardless of
who's speaking like you're always gonna
be drawn to the strongest character on
screen whenever there are a bunch of
people in focus at the same time usually
the camera will pull focus on whichever
character is speaking in the one that
they want you to pay attention to but
when everyone's standing together and
it's kind of confusing you're just kind
of drawn to whoever's the most important
and in most cases that is Felicity pay
attention to whatever you're watching
arrow to because sometimes they'll do
that whenever Oliver's on screen too
like he's the lead but they'll pull
focus on Felicity so it's like saying
that Felicity is more important than
Oliver which is kind of funny and
speaking of strong females I totally
love irises line but she said sometimes
a girl has to save herself it's just
very telling for where all the
arrowverse females are this year like
they're seriously stepping up their game
powers or no powers err on the flash are
just really good at doing strong women
number 2 Barry gets his powers back and
then some using an electrical charge to
get his powers back was very similar to
what happened in flashpoint paradox in
the comic he had to completely recreate
the accident that gave him powers the
first time and he had to do it twice
actually they had all the chemicals like
we saw on Barry's lab and there was a
bolt of electricity like a bolt of
lightning on the show they used the
treadmill because Cisco had its power
jacked way way up that's why he's able
to run so fast on it it has like
megawatts of electricity going through
it the line that he had when he said it
didn't work was another reference to
flashpoint remember I said he had to get
struck by two bolts of lightning the
first time he got struck it just burnt
him like crispy chicken the second time
it worked and he was able to heal
himself instantly if you've ever seen
The Simpsons where Homer tries to jump
Springfield gorge on the skateboard it'd
be like him failing falling down and
then getting up and jumping it again the
flashpoint comic in general was actually
really important to this story Farooq
was a character from the story and
flashpoint was also a big time travel
story so it's no coincidence that the TV
show is pushing into time travel more
mostly via Harrison wells in his
computer he Gideon whose name we
actually learned we didn't know the
gideon name before this episode or that
it had an artificial intelligence
the big takeaway now is the Barry has
more access to his powers than he ever
did before the producers said that you
know Barry will slowly evolve as the
flash over time that also includes his
costume - that's right the costume that
he's wearing now is gonna evolve they're
gonna get a new flash costume soon I
think they said there'd be up to three
different versions of it in season 1 so
I would expect a new flash costume in
the second half of the season but we can
talk about that after episode 9 in terms
of new powers I think on the horizon
we're gonna be seeing him phase through
objects that still feels a long ways off
we're slowly closing the gap between him
brushing his teeth really fast and him
busting into other dimensions there's
like a lot of stuff he has to do between
now and then like he has to have like
his big Empire Strikes Back moment where
he confronts the reverse-flash and gets
ass handed to him big time think about
it this way the amount buried jumps
forward in terms of ability is directly
proportional to the challenges that he
faces so that means the more his ass
gets kicked or the harder he gets kicked
the more his abilities will jump forward
that's why him meeting the reverse-flash
is like one of the big turning points of
the season the producers did say a
little bit about what's gonna happen
when the two of them meet so I'll
explain after my top five moments and my
number one moment of course we learned
all about Harrison wells plan and Gideon
lots of questions answered but I did not
feel like they significantly answered
yes or no who is he really they just
added a little bit more evidence to the
pile let's start with the language he
used when he was talking to his computer
the future is still intact and then when
he said to Cisco of all my inventions
the flash is the most important right
off the bat I think we have a modified
flashpoint paradox storyline going on
here originally the producers said that
they were sticking really close to the
flash rebirth storyline which is a
totally different series of events so
now I think it's just a combination of
both rebirth is Barry Allen's origin
story retold flashpoint paradox is a
story of what happens when Barry Allen
and the reverse-flash mess with the
timeline they're both responsible for
messing things up but Barry is the one
that has to fix it after the Gideon
scenes it seems like Harrison wells is
the self-appointed protector of the
timeline he has that futuristic computer
so I think he's still either working
with someone from the future like the
reverse flash or he is the reverse flash
in the future and the version of him
that we're seeing is stuck in the past
without powers I know there are some
theories about him being a future
version of Barry Allen that's stuck in
the past without powers I don't think
that that's the case even though he does
look a lot like Grant Gustin time loops
are really confusing so I'll give mad
props to the writers of the flash for
explaining the paradox in a really
relatable way the show will be doing
time travel they've confirmed it like
they've said we will deal with
time-travel directly I highly recommend
that you go out and read flashpoint
paradox or watch the animated movie if
you've never seen it it's another Geoff
Johns story totally awesome so just the
fact that wells named his computer
Gideon is another big thing - Gideon was
the judge of the Israelites in the
Hebrew Bible his story is part of the
book of Judges Gideon is also considered
a saint in the Catholic Church
so this is kind of an oversimplification
of his story in the Bible but he's
chosen by God to get the Israelites to
believe in the one true God himself and
turn away from false idols he succeeds
but then after his death everyone starts
worshipping other gods again there's a
flash storyline written by Geoff Johns
where there's a character named Libra
who in Latin means the weighing of
scales his symbol just implies balance
it's the constellation Libra Harrison
Wells has a lot of those ideas in his
character he's not overtly bad or good
he's just trying to balance the future
that doesn't mean he's the Libra
character from the comics but it's
another possibility so here's my big
question for you guys do you think that
he is Libra or do you still think that
he's professor zoom remember he's going
to develop a method for stealing the
Flash's powers but even as evil as that
sounds he could also use that ability to
steal the reverse Flash's powers so not
evil not good either so aside from all
the flashpoint in the Libra stuff the
biggest Easter eggs I saw were all the
names that Harrison wells rattled off
when he was getting ready to be killed
he named Ralph Denby who was elongated
man will Everett who was amazing man al
Rothstein atom smasher from JSA BIA
DaCosta who was a hero named fire grant
Emerson aka damage and of course Ronnie
Raymond who we know is gonna come back
pretty soon as firestorm if you saw any
other Easter eggs that I didn't mention
in the video so far just add them below
in the comments but overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus amazing flash
storyline but the police-station clock
King storyline just felt a little uneven
I'm actually not even sure if the
episode needed a clock King like they
could have cut that entire part of the
episode out although Robert Knepper
always amazing always more prison-break
actors please please bring more of them
on I just I'd love that the show is
snagged so many of them like half of the
Rogues are gonna turn out to be from
Prison Break it's gonna be such an
amazing metaphor my favorite actor from
the episode Tom Cavanagh once again
totally the most interesting character
in the series right now I'm starting to
understand why he was chosen for this
role or why he chose to take on this
role arguably I mean he's a big enough
actor to headline his own series
usually when bigger actors sign on for a
part like this like a smaller part it's
because secretly it's gonna turn out to
be a really big part in the future we're
starting to see that unfold now
but the tease is is that his character
is gonna be much much bigger later in
the series I'm totally feeling the team
flash jam that Caitlin Cisco and Barry
have going on right now they work so
well together that they feel like family
at this point
just like team arrow and that's the
reason why I think that both of these
shows are so much better than all the
other comic book shows out there right
now
a lot of that has to do with the actors
performances and just the chemistry they
have together but it really starts with
the writers and the fact that they focus
on writing for characters and not so
much for the spectacle of superpowers
just Whedon actually had this rule about
writing that was really cool he said
fall in love with moments as in moments
between characters don't fall in love
with moves moves being like the big
reveal of Harrison wells having a secret
future computer like that big reveal
means nothing if Barry and team flash
haven't gone through some big journey
together that ties directly to the
Harrison reveal team flash like I said
totally a family right now so whenever
Barry does learn what Harrison is really
doing it's just gonna have this big
resounding impact and we the audience
will be like holy Greg Berlanti
andrew kriesberg Geoff Johns all the
other writers are really good at
focusing on moments that's why like I
would say of all the shows I'm watching
right now err on the flash - the most
fun shows that is why whenever they
finally do reveal who Harrison wells
really is it's not gonna matter like
we'll just be like so taken back by the
betrayal of team flash that it doesn't
matter who he's gonna be whether he's
professor zoom or Libra or someone else
on to big news so the producer said that
when Barry Allen beats the reverse-flash
he's gonna have his face blurred so
Barry will not see who the reverse flash
is and neither will we the audience like
they're gonna hold that close to their
vest probably till the finale next year
not a big surprise he's like the biggest
flash villain in the history of
everything so of course they're gonna
hold that reveal off next week though is
the two-part crossover the fluoro
crossover if I have time I'll do an
extra bonus video for it be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be like the most awesome two-hour movie
of television you've ever seen think of
it as like a TV Justice League movie
quick reminder new mobile links up here
it's the same as the links that I add
over here but right now click here to
catch up on arrow and click here for
last week's flash thank you so much for
watching
it's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you